hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast how to utilize the power of
CRISPR in your research it is presented
by an ER on skee PhD the product manager
for engineered cells its synth ago I am
Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by synth ago for more
information about our sponsor please
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor active we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located in the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Ron ski I will now turn the presentation
over to her thank you and it's my
pleasure to be speaking to the
laboratorians
to really help people understand how to
utilize the power of CRISPR in their
research so what I would like to go
through today is really go through what
CRISPR is and what it can do for
researchers today it's an incredibly
powerful tool and then also go through
what is required to have a successful
CRISPR experiment which is obviously
integral to using this tool in your
research so I'll go through how to
design an experiment how to edit
actually it can conduct the editing and
then how to analyze the results at the
end of that experiment which is
obviously pivotal to knowing whether it
worked properly or not so what is CRISPR
CRISPR actually stands for clustered
regularly interspaced short palindromic
regions try not to say that too fast
and so this is a really powerful
technique that as of a couple of years
ago has become a little too a lot of how
we're doing research today and it's
really helping to advance the the way
that we can conduct research and the
kind of insects were able to get and so
what does Christmas actually do because
we can precisely change DNA sequences
and this is very different to how we've
been able to modulate gene expression
using other tools such as RNA I so
CRISPR uses two different complexes what
we called a guide RNA and the cast iron
protein itself and these two complexes
come together to form a rather nuclear
protein which when it goes into the cell
finds homology to that guide RNA
sequence which we designed to target
part of the genome so once that complex
has found that DNA that the whole rmp
complex it will make a double-stranded
break and that is all the CRISPR cast
out system actually does once it makes
that double-stranded break obviously
that's in the genomic DNA that's not
something the cell wants to put up with
and so the cell will try to repair that
using a process called non-homologous
end joining and this is whereby the cell
will try to put insertions or deletions
within that that cut site to try to
repair it so that the cell can go on and
still be living and stable and so using
this type of which on a break we can
cause a protein knockout so how do we
actually do this using CRISPR so if we
remember back to our central dogma of
genetics our DNA in the genomic DNA gets
transcribed into mRNA which then gets
translated into protein and so if we
make an insertion or deletion at the
genomic DNA level that's then going to
affect the open reading frame that the
mRNA makes and then thereby the protein
sequence that is utilized and what
typically happens with prospectus 9 when
we get those insertions or deletions
created is that we change the open
reading frame that the mRNA utilizes and
then the that means that we get a
premature stop codon from the protein
level which causes a truncation of
protein and usually nonsense media the
decay
to then have a knockout of protein
function so using non non-homologous end
joining we can get that complete protein
knockout but then there's also another
side of CRISPR that we can utilize and
so this is where we can use donor
template in addition to the cast 9 and
the guide RNA to do more precise genome
engineering and so this is where we can
use that during the template for when
that double-stranded cut is made it can
then more precisely fix that
double-stranded break by inserting or
deleting precise pieces of DNA which we
stipulate on that during a template now
one thing to note is that for homologous
recombination or that process of knockin
and inserting or deleting precisely
pieces of DNA that's a very inefficient
process for the cell to take so in terms
of the kinds of editing efficiency that
were able to get for knock Ian's using
her modest recombination we often get
very low editing efficiency so double
digits is it's usually a very favorable
outcome whereas for knockouts using
non-homologous end joining were able to
get much higher editing efficiencies and
were able to achieve upwards of ninety
percent depending on the guide and the
cell line and so it's really important
that that you're aware of that because
it still is a challenging technique to
do it knock in so how can we use this
entire system for use in your research
so CRISPR is obviously a very powerful
technique using non-homologous end
joining or just making knockouts we're
able to do a lot of different things
such as study the protein function using
a knockout to do a loss-of-function
experiment we can use knockout cell
lines to validate your antibody or your
assay to ensure that they're binding or
functioning correctly and then we can
also use it for pathway analysis to
identify which parts of a pathway is
integral to the function that you're
looking at and then using knockings or
hamaji directed repair were able to do
things like disease modeling where we
can insert snip or codon changes to
reflect disease States we can
endogenously tag proteins which was
previously very difficult to do without
CRISPR and then
for other things we can more precisely
insert or delete pieces of DNA which
obviously has a wide range of
applications so how does nuclear go as a
company approach the way we do CRISPR
and we do things a little bit
differently to the vast majority of life
science companies that are out there and
we really apply the concepts of
engineering on to how we do biology so
what does that actually mean it means
that we use the facets of design build
test and learn to really iterate on how
we're doing biology and we're placing
this on top of genome engineering so
this means that we're do things in
parallel we try to rapidly iterate on
how we do things we try to do things at
scale as well as you guys Automation to
help us be able to do all of these
different things and we apply this on
things like how we build things to the
hardware that we utilize the bio
informatics tools that were using for
CRISPR cast 9 as well as the chemistry
that we're building to be able to make
that our agents for example and then we
utilize all of this to be able to
improve how we're analyzing biology and
for example how we're making engineered
cells and so we utilize all of these
different things to be able to combine
them together into what we call the full
stack of genome engineering so this is
really in sort of engineering terms the
full workflow of how you can do a CRISPR
cast an experiment this includes how you
design the experiment how you actually
do the editing and then finally how you
do the analysis and so we combine all of
these into what we call the full stack
solutions and so we have CRISPR
revolution kids where we can make the
synthetic chemically modified guide RNAs
for use in your own cells we provide
already edited cells within our
engineered cells portfolio and then we
underpin both of these different
products with our biomedics tools which
I'll talk about in a little bit just to
really reiterate how we can provide that
full stack of genome engineering
solutions and we really integrate all of
these into that one product line of
engineered cells to be able to get the
very best editing outcomes and I'll show
you some of that
as I go through this presentation and so
from that design edit and analyze what
we really tried to do as a company is
identify
where people were getting stuck where
are the difficulties that people find in
doing a CRISPR experiment and how can we
improve them for the entire scientific
community so they can really utilize
this fantastic tool and so we've
identified multiple different points and
I'll just touch on a few of them so this
includes how do we build more effective
reagents to do CRISPR experiments how
can we optimize to a greater degree so
we can get better success rates how do
we analyze these experiments and have
more high throughput and informative
fashion and then how can we as a company
be able to provide solutions that are
flexible and affordable to the
scientific community so I'm starting off
with effective reagents so we have we
designed our own design tools so that we
can better design guide RNAs which are
obviously integral to how we do across
the cosine experiment and so our design
tool takes into multiple different
facets so we look at the early coding
region of any gene when we design our
guides because as I showed you
previously we want to ensure that when
we're designing a guide we're hitting an
early exon so that we can we can knock
out that protein function as early on as
we can so we don't get a protein
transcripts created in addition we try
to find a common exon from many genes
there's multiple transcripts that are
coming off that particular piece of DNA
so we want to ensure that when we design
a guide we're able to target every every
every transcript in addition something
that's very important for CRISPR editing
is being able to control the off target
effects so one of the ways we can do
this is through the design of the guides
and for any engine it sells product or
project what we try to do is include as
many mismatches as we can so that that
piece of guide RNA that we're using
doesn't have very high affinity
elsewhere in the genome and so we often
try to do at least three mismatches to
elsewhere in the genome to ensure that
we're minimizing the off target effects
as much as possible we also do this
without reagent design which I'll touch
on in a little bit and then finally we
try to find guides that have a high
activity and so there's multiple
different scores that people use
to really try to rank diet and identify
based on sequence what kind of guide
will be predicted to work better and
from our computing power and from it the
ability to automate a lot of the
processes that we have in-house we're
actually able to test some of these
assumptions does a non-target score
actually equate to better editing
efficiency so we actually did this
experiment in-house and using thousands
of different guide RNAs and looking at
the five different algorithms that are
usually used or on target scores as you
can see from this data where we have the
predicted editing efficiency on the
x-axis and then the observed on the
y-axis you can see that there's actually
no correlation for any of these
algorithms between the predicted score
and then the actual score and so what
this means is that currently is a field
we don't have a great way of predicting
editing efficiency just from the guide
sequence alone there's obviously a lot
of other complexity that is going into
this that is affecting our ability to
edit at any specific location the other
side of that is that we need to tried
multiple guides for any one gene or
location because we are we don't have
good ways of predicting which one will
actually work so the best strategy is to
try at least three guides to ensure that
you're getting the best results possible
because you may be getting low editing
simply because of the guide selection
the other thing that we can try to do is
increase the way that we're actually the
reagents that we're actually using for
CRISPR experiments and so we at some
degree have pioneered own a way of
synthesizing synthetic chemically
modified single guide RNAs so these are
ones that are chemically modified at the
5-prime and 3-prime ends of the guide
itself were the three bases at the five
prime three prime end and what they're
does is it helps reduce the the
exonuclease degradation that occurs for
the guide as well as does not trigger an
immune response which other other
formats may because their RNA that
floating around in the cell and as you
can see here we this also combined in
leads to an improved editing efficiency
in comparison to IBT guide so we're able
to have a huge increase in editing
efficiency just from the format and so
talking about format there's lots of
different ways that people have made
CRISPR reagents and so there's been a
very big evolution in in those reagents
so at the very beginning a lot of people
use plasmids to introduce the CRISPR
reagent so the Casman and the guide RNA
this required cloning into a plasmid and
preparation and unfortunately a lot of
these plasmids had cytotoxicity because
there were large pieces of DNA that the
cell just didn't really like they also
could integrate into the site which one
we're doing precise genome engineering
is obviously not ideal and one of the
biggest issues that plasmids have is
that they have a long half-life so what
that means is when we over expressed
caste 9 for example using a plasmid we
often still seek after nine expression
even 72 hours after editing has occurred
and so what that means is that even
though we've already done made the
double-stranded break when the cell has
repaired it that Castellon and guide are
still floating around and can
potentially have other off-target
effects and so many people have now
demonstrated that using a plasmid
approach leads to much higher off target
effects and again you can't chemically
modify them the the plasmids so we
aren't able to improve the editing
efficiency just through those kinds of
modifications you can also make your own
guides using a big clip transcription
this usually is very labor-intensive as
well as usually carries along a lot of
impurities because this is an in vitro
way of synthesizing guides that leads to
lower editing efficiencies and again you
can't chemically modify them to them and
prove those editing efficiencies there
is synthetic chemically modified guides
that come in two pieces and this is
called the 2-piece or the CRISPR tracer
RNA guides and they are synthetic and
they are chemically modified but because
you have to do a pre annealing step
before you anneal it to the caste 9 to
make the ribonucleoprotein this leads to
inefficient annealing and thereby
inefficient editing as well and so
lastly what we would recommend
especially for hard to transfer cell
lines is to maximize your editing
efficiency to use the synthetic
single guide RNA that's
we modified and so these are very pure
they're very well tolerated by cells and
for especially for hot transfect cells
and because we're able to chemically
modify them and their transiently
expressed in the cell so they have lower
half-life but still get very high
editing efficiencies so this the
germline effective editing is still
present and we get reduced off target
effects and then we've actually compared
the two different formats that are
synthetic and chemically modified so the
CRISPR tracer and the single guide RNA
we do see that we can improve editing
efficiency even further so this is Dana
where we looked at nearly 40 different
guide RNAs using both the CRISPR tracer
from ourselves and different different
vendors as well as a synthetic single
guide our name and so what you can see
in this is that for some guides you're
always going to get low editing
efficiency and this is likely to be an
influence of the sequence itself rather
than the format of guides that were
using in this experiment there's also
going to be instances where the the
editing efficiency doesn't really change
depending on what format we use and so
this you know you could easily use a
CRISPR tracer for this however what we
most commonly see is that you get a
decrease in editing efficiency depending
on that format so using a synthetic
single grade RNA gives you the highest
editing efficiency and then with every
different format that we use we losing
editing efficiency so we're still
getting relatively good with our CRISPR
tracer but with other vendors they're
not usually as high quality and so we
lose everything efficiency for that and
so one thing that we would recommend is
using synthetic single guide RNAs
because that ensures that you're always
going to get the highest editing
efficiency possible so once you have
your guides how do we then actually
utilize those in our experiment and one
thing that I would always recommend is
optimizing the the way that your
transfecting and we if possible we
recommend electroplating your guide and
cast nine into the cell as an RMP
because that will usually give you the
highest editing efficiency and we
usually see about 2/3 reduction in
editing efficiency if we use lipid-based
transfection
and one thing
that we had some to go do is we really
embrace our ability to fail which you
know as this quote from Thomas Edison
very nicely the pecs in general
scientists usually very good at failing
and a troubling failure it's just
finding a lot of ways that don't work
and so what we try to do is really
identify the best conditions by letting
ourselves find ways that don't work and
so this is really nicely depicted with
how we actually automate that
optimization process for engineered
cells so any cell line that we take in
to do an engineered cells product or
project with we test 200 different
conditions for that optimization so for
example when we did this in th p1 cells
we test at least 200 different
conditions and using the manufacturers
protocol we would have gotten about 7%
knockout efficiency so this knockout
score is actually a score of the
insertions and deletions that are going
to cause a frameshift rather than just
all insertions and deletions because
there might be some that won't and I'll
touch on this in a second and how we
determine this however you can see here
that when we were able to optimize we
were able to go from 7% all the way up
to 72% and so this is a huge improvement
in the editing efficiency and we because
we have this automated and high
throughput process this took us only
three days and this really most of that
time was in waiting for the results to
come back and so we do this for every
single cell line that comes in as I
mentioned and so this is just some of
the cell lines that we've been able to
optimize and the high knockout scores
we've been able to achieve with these
cells so once you've actually done your
experiment how do you analyze it and so
historically there's been really two
different ways of analyzing CRISPR
experiments one has been using the t71
or surveyor assays and so how these
assays function is if you make a
double-stranded break with CRISPR you're
able to once your PCR amplify around
that region you'll get an applicant of
of that double-stranded break which will
have mismatches to its other template
one at the PCR amplified and then we can
use a nucleus to be able to digest at
those mismatches that t7 nucleus and you
can resolve that on Adi
nygel so this is very qualitative
obviously very time-consuming so the
other way that people were doing was
with amplicon seek so this is where you
would PCR amplify around the cut site
and then send that in for next-gen
sequencing so what how do these are
these two these two methodologies
actually compare so ones obviously very
qualitative NGS is very quantitative but
very laborious and so unfortunately
these two techniques don't really
compare to each other so this is data
generated by Chandra Miller cruet who
runs the Washu genome engineering core
and what she was able to show in this
publication that was published this year
was that when she compared
next-generation sequencing results to
t71 there was actually no correlation
between the two and worst of all in most
cases in every case t71 vastly
underrepresented the actual editing
efficiency that you got and at the worst
situation you could actually you know
80-71 would tree that you've got 10%
editing when actually you were able to
get 90% editing and this could really
change how you do the next steps and the
kind of things that and the kind of work
that you need to put in and so we
obviously wanted a method that was
easier to do then next-gen sequencing
but a lot more a lot more comprehensive
and more accurate than the t71
or surveyor assay and so what we decided
upon is kind of the middle ground of the
two so what we do internally and for any
engineered cells project is we PCR
amplify around the cut site and then we
send that in for Sanger sequencing and
we've developed our own software tool
that is able to do convolute the
chromatograms that come out of sign of
sequencing to give us a relative view of
the kind of insertions and deletions
that the CRISPR cast nine has created so
we call this eyesore inference of CRISPR
editing it is available from our website
so you just click on find somatic stores
and ice analysis and you're able to
access it or just go to is simply go
calm it has free batch uploads and all
of ice is completely free it has
automatic window that will set the ideal
settings for your for your experiment
and then you get publication quality
results and data and we're always
updating this as well so I'll talk about
that in a second so this is what ice
looks like all we have to do is put in
your guide sequence and then drag and
drop or select your control ad one file
as well as your edited a B one file and
then hit analysis you can also do batch
upload and we have in our example files
if you download those there's examples
of how to structure those definition
files so they are able to do batch
upload as well if you have multiple
samples and we can accept after 700
samples if you're doing a huge and
editing experiment and so this is what
the outcome looks like so this is the
first view that you see and how what the
important thing that we show you is that
I score which is the total editing
efficiency as well as the KO score so
this is that score that I was talking
about that gives you the percentage of
insertions and deletions that are going
to cause a frameshift so it removes any
things that are integers of 3 and also
includes things that are large deletions
and we can use ice for multiplexing
which I won't show you but we do have
some great articles on our website with
habit how to use multiplexing for your
experiments if that's what you are after
and the really cool thing that ice shows
you that's really informative is
actually the percentage of each
insertion or deletion that is present in
that population that saying a sequencing
was able to detect so as you can see
from this example the highest
contribution that we have in this
population is a minus 2 deletion that's
in about 68% of that population so this
is really informative for future
experiments that we want to do down the
line as well as if you wanted to take
these cells and criminally expand them
and make a clone or cell line and when
we compare eyes to other techniques such
as tide or next-gen sequencing using a
pecan seek we're able to get very good
correlation between these techniques and
we did we have published a manuscript on
bio archive if anyone is interested
which can be very easily found if you
want more details and this software is
also available and github if anyone is
so inclined to dig around at that code
so once we have you know an ability to
analyze these results how do we put all
of this together to give you the best
flexibility for your CRISPR experiments
and obviously CRISPR is it's not an easy
tool to set up in your lab
it does seem relatively simple but
there's a lot of things that you have to
have to consider including all of these
things that I mentioned and and others
and so as a company what we wanted to do
is provide a solution that gives people
the maximum amount of flexibility to be
able to utilize the power of prosper in
their work and so we have three
different product lines that depict
engineered cells which the goal of which
is to really provide unprecedented
access to this fantastic CRISPR
technology so the first is knock out
cell pools where we make a poly clonal
population of cells for you and I'll
explain that in further detail we can
also take those to clean on and then we
have an advance of category which
includes Nokia's
and other complicated editing
experiments so for knockout cell pools
we can quickly and successfully generate
these cells where we design and
synthesize the guide RNA we edit those
cells and then we send your quality
control report and you get two vials of
knockout cells two bars of bar hype
cells and then a product summary and
depending on the doubling time of the
cells and how well they survived
post-nuclear affection this takes
between four to ten weeks and so what
you get is guaranteed protein knockout
and so we have very very strong current
units for these products this includes
if we don't get at least 50% editing we
will either redo the experiments and all
go back to you and decide what what we
should do next but we won't charge you
for it in addition if you get the cells
you test them in your own lab and you
don't see a 50% reduction in protein
within 48 hours we will also go back and
either redo the project or refund your
your purchase price in addition we also
have a viability guarantee so this means
if we conduct your knock out and do to
the biology of the the gene that we've
knocked out it's integral to cell
survival if we see a reduction in the
knock out efficiency due to that and it
goes under 50% we
also refund your money so we're really
trying to provide no risk CRISPR
knockouts you also obviously get the the
report including the insertions and
deletions through ice as well as primer
sequences so that you can redo that ice
analysis once you have the cells in your
lab and then a certificate of analysis
showing that the cells are freed from
mycoplasma as well as a visual sterility
test now one question that we often get
is well what really are these pools of
cells that we're getting and whether
they these are required to go clonal and
oftentimes because using our automated
platform and our amazing synthetic
single guide RNAs were able to get such
high editing efficiency that these pores
could be useful without actually having
to go clonal which saves you a lot of
time and potentially money so these
pores of cells are obviously polyclonal
populations which contain different
insertions and deletions and the vast
majority of these are likely going to be
ones that cause a frameshift because
they're not integers of three so all of
those different insertions and deletions
are going to cause a protein knock out
and so if we have a high enough
efficiency pool and were generally being
able to generate pores that are about 70
percent editing efficiency so very high
editing efficiency pause this can often
be used directly for assays or if we go
clonal we can often get very great
success rates with chronal as well and
so for example this is a product that we
shipped to a customer where we're able
to get very high editing efficiency and
when they looked at protein expression
using for cytometry as you can see in
the figure on the right they were able
to get the the protein expression in the
knockout cells was might was almost the
same as the negative control and almost
a complete protein knockout in
comparison to the wild-type and so if
this protein was responsible for a
functional phenotype these cells would
very strongly show that phenotype
because we've been able to completely
knock out the protein function in
addition there's obviously cases in
which you have to go clonal and we would
recommend this if your knock out is cool
some sort of population drift where
you're editing population is being
reduced because the cells are
proliferating much slower or they're
undergoing apoptosis in the condition of
their wild-type cells and so in most
cases it's also easy to go to clonal
population using that highly edited pool
and so for example if we were to take
our pool with higher earning efficiency
and plate those into single cell plating
using 0.5 cells per well using one
96-well plate we're able to screen about
29 wells so this is the the problem the
number of wells by a probability that
we're going to get only one cell per
well and not zero or more than one and
so of those 29 because of that 80%
editing efficiency were able to see at
least 22 edited clones so this is a
really large number of clones for not
much work on the flip side if you were
to do this yourself and for example
using a 20% edited pool you would need
to screen for 96 well plates which would
mean 343 wells that need to be imaged
need to ensure that they're single cell
need to be media changed expanded splits
phenotyped and of those you'd only get 6
edited coins in contrast to the 22 that
you get with only one 96 well plate if
you used ourselves and in addition we
provide a limiting dilution and clonal
expansion protocol that gives some of
the tips and tricks that we use
internally to try to get better clonal
expansion outcomes and so we highly
recommend following some of those tricks
and this is freely available on our
website on the resource page the other
question we often get using knock out
cell pools is well how many alleles are
actually edited in these cells and so
although we cannot see this in a pool
because there's lots of different
insertions and deletions that may
contribute this when we take those
opposed to clonal we're able to see what
that kind of what the homozygosity hydro
zygosity of the edit was and the answer
is because we have such high editing
efficiency we're able to see that all
alleles in general are edited and so
from you can see
here we see really high editing
efficiency and all of the alleles are
edited even in an unemployed cell line
and so it's actually more difficult for
us to get ahead like this edit although
we can't do it just requires screening
more clones and so we're able to very
confidently say that the majority of the
editing that were able to do because of
its so high editing efficiency will
result in homozygous knockout so for the
knockout cell calls we have over 700
cell lines available are these all human
cell lines and they can ship in as few
as four weeks if you if you wanted to do
a knockout cell with us all you have to
do is go to our website and type in
their cell line and the gene name if
both of those get filled you can
literally just add to cart' generate a
quote and because beyond a submit appeal
against it's as simple as that and of
course if you do want to talk to us
about the process we're always happy to
talk as well and again these are all
guaranteed protein knockout or we don't
invoice
their final purchase price so there's
always places where people would like us
to just do the clonal steps for them as
well and so we take a slightly different
approach to knock out clonal cells in
this we use a milestone approach where
we do several different stages and
consult with you and communicate how
we're doing at each step because this is
a longer time frame because we have to
go coin on so the first step is we on
board the cells where we have to procure
the cells often we have to expand them
and then ensure that actually tests that
they can get to single cell clonal cell
state because obviously we want to be a
but know about to make sure that we can
make a coin or sign at the end of the
project we then edit the cells where we
optimize we make the guide RNAs we then
transfer and then analyze that pool of
cells which we then take into single
cell clonal expansion and as you'll see
this takes the longest period of time
anywhere between five to twelve weeks
depending on how well the cells grow it
out of clonal from that clonal deletion
the other thing that we do at this step
is we image the cells every couple of
days to ensure that we're tracking the
cells and that we're only getting a
single cell clonal population from in
each well and
obviously discard any wells that are
coming from two cells this ensures that
we're able to screen clonal populations
and then we also validate this during
the validation step in our quality
control to ensure that the cells that
we're expanding and growing up for coin
or delivery only monoclonal cells and
aren't a result of two potential clonal
populations coming together and when we
have generated some of these were able
to show a very strong functional
outcomes because we have clonal
knockouts so in this example we took C
to c12 cells which is a myoblast cell
line and we knocked out the my OD one
cell now my d1 gene
excuse me and so these cells are ones
that can differentiate from a Maya blast
into a Maya tube and you can see on the
images here on the right when we have no
guide RNA and we've differentiated these
cells they're able to very effectively
differentiate into these myotubes but
when we block my OD one by knocking it
out which disturbs that that
differentiation process we're able to
see that we now no longer have myotubes
being formed as you can see in that
third panel on them on the right and so
and this really does depict that were
able to be able to find functional
clones that have a functional phenotype
which is obviously what you're looking
for in using CRISPR as a resource for
your protein knockouts so a knockout
cell lines are available again in those
700 cell lines immortalized human cell
lines and the turnaround time is longer
because of that kind of process the
price point is also higher at $15,000
per coin and this is really attributed
to how long it takes to be able to get
that coin or cell line again it's
completely guaranteed and so if we
aren't able to get you that coin we will
give you your money back and we will
work with you at all of the steps to
ensure that we're getting the best
product possible so obviously this is a
very high price point for lot of
researchers and so this is why we have
really tried to make knockout cell pools
a more viable option for a lot of people
where you can either get a functional
pool and be able to use that directly or
take that to clone or yourself because
of the high editing efficiency this is
so much
simpler than trying to do this yourself
so finally we have advanced cells so
these are cells in which encompass other
editing experiments that are more
complicated so this includes not Koons
as well as other mammalian cell types
that aren't human
and so in in advanced cells were able to
generate these more complex cell lines
so this includes designing and
synthesizing both the guide as well as
the donor template if we need to utilize
a donor for a knockin we then edit the
cells isolate them and do clonal quality
control testing and so all locking
experiments are currently delivered as
clone or cell lines what you get is two
single cell clones as well as a project
summary which is also detailed during
that mastering process so we also use
that milestone process for naki and
clonal projects or advance of clonal
projects this is include all of those
other steps including onboarding those
cells checking for single cell
chronology ability designing and making
all the reagents editing them and
expanding them into single cell clones
and doing those that final QC and
validation and so advanced cells
encompasses more of those complex
editing reactions but usually are quite
difficult for people to attain in the
lab because as I mentioned at the very
beginning homology directed repair which
is the mechanism by which we do knock
ins
is much much less preferable by the cell
and so getting double-digit knocking
everything efficiency is quite frankly
phenomenal and we're able internally to
be able to get anywhere between 10 to 20
percent knockin efficiencies which is
which is amazing and this is because
we're able to optimize so many of these
processes in a high-throughput way so
these advanced cells include things like
snip changes codon changes tagging genes
including GFP as well as other tags both
biochemical and fluorescent tags as well
as insertions and includes some of those
more difficult immortalize mammalian
cell lines including mouse and rat cell
lines and we can deliver both coin or
cell lines in about 10 to 20 weeks so
what I've hope I've shown you today is
that within engineered cells since the
goal is trying to provide unprecedented
access to this CRISPR technology in a
very affordable and slow
of all men are peopIe being able to
provide high editing efficiency pause
which can be utilized directly by
knockout cell clients and then advanced
cells which encompasses those more
complex editing efficiencies and we're
able to do this by really combining our
full stack genome engineering solution
so this includes using the most
effective reagents using those modified
single guide RNAs which give us both the
best editing efficiency as well as the
lowest off-target rate including using
our design tool which incorporates all
of those design metrics that I mentioned
earlier we optimized our methodology to
ensure we're getting the best editing
efficiency possible and we have
developed these great analysis tools to
be able to make better analysis and more
informative analysis in a quicker
turnaround time and then finally we're
able to because we have such high energy
efficiency provide flexible options that
are affordable for all researchers so
with that I encourage you to really
utilize your time in discovering those
amazing things that all of you research
is are doing and we really want to be
able to help you in doing this by
optimizing the CRISPR for you and being
able to generate these resources for
your experiments rather than you having
to do that yourself so if you're
interested please contact us at the
address below and would be happy to talk
you through the options and in addition
I'd like to give a shout out to our
amazing blog called the bench this has
lots of different stories and really
cool things that people are doing with
CRISPR so if you're interested in
ensuring that you're up to date with the
best CRISPR news I would highly
recommend subscribing to the blog so
thank you so much for your attention and
with that I will take any questions
thank you doctor on ski for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started first question is
how do you guarantee that you will get
50% editing that's a great question and
so we not just guarantee 50% we
guarantee at least 50% and so we're able
to provide this guarantee because of the
high level of optimization and the
automated process that we do so as we do
any experiment we obviously optimize
those 200 conditions that I mentioned we
also train multiple guides at the same
time so we're able to pick the best one
and not waste any time and lose any time
and going back and trying something else
and then because we have this full stack
we're able to see these things really
quickly so we're really very well
positioned because of the automated
platform that would be being able to
built out to be able to deliver these
really high living efficiency sorry that
really is why we have the power to give
that guarantee and such a low price
point thank you for that next one is
what about off target effects do you
assess those yeah that's a great
question and one that always comes up so
obviously everyone is concerned about
off target effects of CRISPR and the
thing that we tend to see is that using
both well-designed guides like we are
doing with our design tool and utilizing
the synthetic chemically modified single
guide RNA format using an RMP to deliver
those cells but able to see usually less
than 1% of off target effects and
usually much even note that off target
effects we don't analyze those as part
of an engineered cells project but we do
give you the guide RNA sequence that
we've used and using our design tool
there's a validate portion on that where
you can type in that guide sequence and
identify where potential of target
effects may occur you can then use that
information to develop for example a
Sanger sequencing strategy to be able to
identify whether or not off target
effects have actually occurred there so
while we don't test for off target
effects at the moment internally we
definitely provide you all the tools to
be able to do so yourself thank you that
looks like we have time for one more
question
do you offer academic pricing absolutely
so one thing that as a company we're
trying to do is be much more accessible
and so obviously some of these services
as provided by other CRA organizations
can cost ten to twenty thousand dollars
and so we definitely have academic
pricing and if you're interested in that
and are from an academic lab you can
actually just ask for academic pricing
directly from our website there's a
little button that says you know I'm an
academic please give me academic pricing
in addition we also offer both
discounting pricing so if you're
interested in doing a lot of projects
with us I'm definitely getting in touch
with us and we can we can offer you even
further discounts for that in addition
if you would like to do the editing
yourself and use the synthetic
chemically modified guides we also have
special pricing commissions on those so
you know for whatever your application
it's definitely worthwhile to get in
touch with us because we cannot usually
offer some really great promotional
discounts to make this more accessible
to people thank you I would like to once
again thank dr. Ron ski for her
presentation would also like to thank
cynth ago for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 27th 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon goodbye